[Musik]
sie beide stehen für die zwei corona
lager in deutschland auf der einen seite
karl lauterbach der spd
gesundheitsexperte der wahner der mahner
der vorsichtige auf der anderen seite
fdp vize wolfgang kubicki
er warnt vor panikmache will mehr
freiheiten
das ko duell jetzt bei die richtigen
fragen ja wunderschönen guten abend hier
aus dem bild live newsroom und uns jetzt
zugeschaltet einen wunderschönen guten
abend an wolfgang kubicki und karl
lauterbach eine wunderschöne 100 erlaubt
aber wir haben sie beide eingeladen weil
sie in den corona position fast
diametral sich gegenüber stehen oft
gestritten haben in den vergangenen
anderthalb jahren wenn sie mal
zurückschauen über welche positionierung
von wolfgang kubicki haben sie sich am
meisten geärgert
also ich muss nicht einmal in den
vordergrund stellen dass ich herrn
kubicki
wolfgang kubicki ich sehr schätze weil
er sehr viel ist und auch immer also an
der sache orientiert argumentiert somit
also das muss im vordergrund stehen das
hat mir eine persönliche die verwahrung
an die 100 persönliche härte gegeben
ich habe am anfang den eindruck gehabt
dass wolfgang kubicki dass die uns
unterschätzt hat die also vehemenz also
mit der das virus tatsächlich menschen
also nicht nur tötet sondern auch
längerfristig also krank machen kann
da hatte ich den eindruck war eher nicht
wirklich offen genug
das ist oder wie gesagt so dass der
eindruck den ich also mitgenommen habe
aber es war immer eine faire debatte
auch unterschiedlicher wagen war herr
kuki hier haben sie das corona virus
verharmlost
wenn ich karl lauterbach wäre würde ich
das so sehen aber in der tat kann ich
für mich in anspruch nehmen dass sie
bereits im letzten jahr im mai darauf
hingewiesen habe dass niemand mehr an
erhalten und pflegeheim kommen sollte er
nicht getestet worden sein
einschließlich der beschäftigten dass
ich darauf hingewiesen habe dass der
beste eigenschutz das tragen einer fft
zwei maske ist aber das ist
vergangenheit also hier geht es ja darum
dass wir als staat immer nur auf einer
rechtsgültigen grundlage arbeiten können
und ich habe das gefühl dass in der
vergangenheit mittlerweile die angst vor
dem virus überhand genommen hat und uns
dafür den blick getrübt hat wie wir mit
vernünftigen maßnahmen lernen mit dem
virus zu leben wenn es nicht wieder aus
der welt bekommen wie oft platzt ihnen
die hutschnur wenn sie lesen was karl
lauterbach so twittert wenn sie seine
interviews hören weil es gibt ja auch
jetzt weiter in der debatte und karl
lauterbach gehört zu denjenigen die
immer wieder warnen und mahnen auch in
dieser phase noch ein guter kollege
lauterbach hat seine rolle gefunden als
die kassandra der republik das nehme ich
ihm gar nicht übel was mich nur ärgert
ist die tatsache dass auch bei ihm wie
bei anderen wie bei entspannen oder
helge braun der immer sozusagen eine ein
ton mit schwingt er uns angst machen
soll wer von incidents ist von 200 bis
800 rede die wir im oktober erreichen
können und die frage zu stellen welche
auswirkungen hat das auf
hospitalisierungen welche auswirkung hat
das auf intensivbetten oder auch
todesfälle der macht menschen angst und
ich habe in meinem leben gelernt es
macht immer sinn menschen mut zu machen
und ihnen die angst zu nehmen statt als
politischer entscheidungsträger und
weiter zu verbreiten das ist nicht meine
methode und zum schluss noch mal wir
sind darauf angewiesen dass wir auf
rechtlicher grundlage uns bewegen und
ich hab das gefühl dass bei vielen
verordnungen der länder aber auch des
bundes manchmal die angst die oberhand
gewinnt und nicht das rationale denken
sind sie ein angstmacher lauterbach will
ich nicht also das ist zum beispiel das
was ich nicht jetzt was ich nicht gab
jetzt läuft die schon über das war über
das band kassandra der radweg das ist
also wenn man so wäre ein pullback es
soll ein polemiker so ich habe sehr sehr
früh sehr häufig auf dinge hingewiesen
die hoffnung machen zum beispiel gehörte
ich zu den ersten die gesagt
wir werden auf jeden fall eine impfung
bekommen wie wäre es mit der impfung
schaffen
wir werden die herden die mobilität
schaffen aber dennoch erlaubt aber
dennoch wir nur den einen noch den
anderen auch so sagen
also wenn ich sage die warnungen waren
mir also entschieden wir
wissenschaftlich nicht haltbar
aber so warten müssen sie so einen
stecker denen man drauf und wir haben
auto hinten einfach braucht was sagen
was vornehmlich um abstand ich könnte
mir fehlen jetzt auch getan die ich
jetzt sagen könnte dies einmal kette
sind die fragen sie doch mal
hinterlassen und die kopie kubicki der
und so weiter und ich mache das was er
nicht
ich schätze das gar nicht wenn man also
mit also mit einer polemischen bemerkung
einem gegenüber war sie einen stempel
draufdrücken will das hilft auch nicht
weiter
aber dass es bei dem thema bleiben herr
lauter war dann lasst uns bei dem thema
bleiben es war der vorwurf der
angstmacherei ihnen gegenüber und als
wir die sendung angekündigt haben auch
im internet bei twitter zum beispiel da
gab es viele menschen die geschrieben
haben bitte fragen sie doch mal den
herrn lauterbach der hat doch zum
beispiel der europameisterschaft davor
gewarnt dass da viel zu viele menschen
im stadion sind das eine riesen gefahr
ausgeht was ist denn jetzt mit diesen
menschen und die sagen sie haben auch
gewarnt vor dem frieden oder den
freiheitstag in großbritannien was sind
denn jetzt die konsequenzen also viele
werfen ihnen eben vor dass sie aufgrund
dieser ereignisse immer wieder warnen
und mahnen und ja angst verbreiten also
wenn ich als arzt also darauf hinweisen
dieses und jedes kann passieren was ist
das zunächst einmal eine mit ist eh
nicht begründbare oder epidemiologisch
begründbare war aber es hat nichts mit
angst zu verfassen und es ist ja
tatsächlich nur die epidemiologischen
studien gehen davon aus dass die us
botschaft und die spiele in england mit
dazu geführt haben dass dort die
fahrbahn so stark gestiegen sind
bis also zu bis zu den
europameisterschafts spielen war es
immer so dass sich mehr frauen als
männer infiziert haben während der
spiele war es erstmal
ungezählt da ist noch einmal nach einer
welle gegeben die app jetzt langsam aber
es ist im großen ganzen genau so
gekommen dann muss man sich studien
anschauen und das ist aber jenseits
dieser frage wer ist derzeit also immer
dass das wird ja hier so ein bisschen
jetzt ausgezogen
hier ist wolfgang kubicki der kämpfer
für die freiheit und hier ist der spd
typ der sozusagen angst war das ist so
pumpt das passt nicht aber stimmt doch
bestimmt nicht ich mache keine angst
sondern nicht beschreiben was will ich
von mir noch nicht bewältigt haben
ich war so zum beispiel darauf hin dass
hohe instituts und auch bedeuten würde
dass wir viele longo gipfel haben
gleichzeitig bin ich aber fest davon
überzeugt dass wir aus so die
herdenimmunität schaffen können und dass
wir dies gemeinsam mit der impfung
bewältigen der erste war hingerissen
herr kubicki wir sind nicht nehmen wie
nehmen sie das wahr die debatten die
jetzt passieren also europameisterschaft
zum beispiel die debatte und
großbritannien da hat man ja schon das
gefühl dass uns da ja ein geredet wurde
dass das erhebliche konsequenzen gibt
und wenn man sich das anschaut dann hat
man jetzt nicht das gefühl oder man
sieht es auch an den zahlen dass
insbesondere die hospitalisierung rate
in großbritannien hochgeschnellt wäre
oder anderes passiert ist also zur
ehrenrettung von karl lauterbach muss
ich sagen dass ich ihm abnehmen dass er
nicht angst verbreiten willen und ist
angst aber immer ein subjektives gefühl
und nur können warnungen und mahnungen
dazu führen dass bei vielen menschen ein
angstsymptome auftritt wer davor warnt
dass wir den 65.000 menschen in ein
stadion gehen dass das was viele
todesfälle nach sich zieht der erzeugt
bei einer reihe von menschen einfach
angst wir wissen das stimmt dass die
infektionszahlen in großbritannien nach
der europameisterschaft wären wir nach
oben gegangen sind wir wissen aber nicht
ob das aus dem stadion gekommen ist oder
nicht vielleicht aus dem papst oder aus
dem privaten zusammenkünften bei denen
leute sich schlicht der graben gelegen
haben
nach dem fussballspiel gesehen wir
wissen mittlerweile und zwar gesichert
karl lauterbach das hohe incidents zahl
bei jüngeren menschen relativ wenig
aussagekraft haben über das pandemie
geschehen weil die relativ selten
schwere verläufe und noch seltener
todesfälle das heißt der instituts von
200 bei unter 20 jährigen ist zwar auch
schlimm muss es aber nicht weiter
beunruhigen im märz wird damit das
gesundheitssystem nicht weil das wofür
ich plädiere und da stimme ich kann auch
dazu wenn man ihm darüber wirklich
wissenschaftlich oder auch vernünftig
politisch diskutieren kann ist dass wir
den menschen das gefühl geben
wir können die pandemien griff bekommen
mit der eigenschutz mir selbst
schutzmaßnahmen hört darauf achten bei
menschenansammlungen die ft2 maske zu
tragen solange er nicht alle durch die
m10 wenn wir darauf achten dass wir
nicht zur rudelbildung neue und andere
dinge mehr
aber allein die tatsache dass jetzt
wieder diskutiert wird eine
flächendeckende tests nicht für menschen
die aus anderen ländern zu uns kommen
reiserückkehrer deutsche dann verbreitet
das nicht vertrauen und mut sondern
verbreitet ist wie der unstimmigkeiten
und aus sorge und angst herr lauterbach
aber wenn wir dann welche darfst also
wir wissen wir sollen ja ein dialog sei
diese sehr vorsichtige positionen die
also gefahren sind die bundesregierung
gefahren wie christian kosten mit also
bestellt hat
diese sehr vorsichtige also
positionierung hat ja auch ihren wert
gehabt sie hat ihren wert gab wir haben
in deutschland an der sterblichkeit gab
die also dort nicht unter der hälfte der
sterblichkeit liegt anderer europäischer
länder die ich sonst mit unserer klar
gewesen sind das haus ist hat sehr viele
menschenleben gerettet
und wenn sie jetzt zum beispiel sagen
das stimmt wir wissen nicht ob jetzt
beispielsweise die menschen die zum
fußball gekommen sind ob sie sich im
stadion also angesteckt hat und oder
nachher im fokus steht aber es ist es
den zusammenhang mit dem europäer mit
der europameisterschaft
das war noch werbung erlaubt aber was
mich interessiert in dem zusammenhang
dass sich viele menschen fragen erlaubt
aber was ist jetzt noch genau das
problem wenn wir uns die
hospitalisierung skater anschauen
dieses niedrig ist es nicht egal wie
hoch die inzidenz schnellt und wenn wir
daran denken
das eben die älteren ja fast durch
geimpft sind also die hohen
altersgruppen unter kubicki
da nicht recht wenn er sagt dass bei den
jungen neben der verlauf nicht so
gravierend ist meistens dann mit diesem
argument könnten wir sagen wir lassen
jetzt alle vorsichtsmaßnahmen weg alles
ist möglich und wir also erlauben quasi
eine komplette durchseuchung der
jüngeren die noch nicht geimpft sind das
nur darauf liefert das jahr hinaus also
ich mache jetzt alles auf ganz normal
ja das war dass uns das nach wie vor der
pandemie und die jungen menschen durch
solche sich komplett das ja der
vorschlag das wird aber epidemiologisch
abgelehnt und zwar aus also drei gründen
der erste grund ist der dass wenn das
dann so viele junge leute wären die sich
infizieren
auch in der gruppe der jüngeren gold es
solche sind die also risikofaktoren
haben die dann tatsächlich auch sterben
ich habe risikorat im leben doch immer
eher lauterbach also ich habe auch
einmal werde ich immer diese daten seien
aber da sagt das ja ein bisschen zu
platt dass das risiko immer da ist also
ich würde dann ja quasi die älteren
wären geimpft und die jüngeren die
wurden durch die behörden der
durchleuchtung ausgeliefert dann müsste
ich bei den jüngeren auf todesfälle bei
denjenigen erwarten die risikofaktoren
an diesem tag gar nicht kennen das
zweite problem ist von den erkan also
das wären dann ja quasi alle grund
sicher infizieren
wie also der wert ist ja etwa 56 das
heißt alle jungen würden sich infizieren
wenn ich jetzt plötzlich alles wieder
zulassen würde dann würde das bedeuten
dass also von denjenigen die sich
infizieren so gut gesprochen er sage ich
wirklich die unterste zahlen damit ich
nicht hier wieder als angstmacher
dargestellt wieder die unterste zahlte
ich sagen kann die ich noch sagen kann
ohne dass ich mich bei den kollegen in
der epidemiologie blamiere
es würden sich mindestens fünf bis zehn
prozent der symptomatik erkannten würden
sich mit long cupid herumschlagen müssen
aber sie konnte und der andere so kommt
die zahl jetzt wieder her
also eine gute zusammenfassung ist die
also ist die zusammenfassung arbeit die
jetzt vor ungefähr zwei wochen in nature
erschienen und das sagt man nochmal aus
allem also studien die es bisher gibt so
longo wird hat man versucht die daten
zusammenzuführen und hat eine samba
gesandt abschätzung versuchte ich kann
ihnen das gerne nach der also nach
unserer henrik aber es gibt halt so
zahlreiche zusammen und ist nur noch
bisschen bitten punkt der dritte punkt
an will nicht durch damit der würde
bedeuten dass wir wenn wir so viele
fälle hätten so war ist offen machen
es liegt für deutsch dann hätten wir
auch durchbruch infektionen bei den
älteren war bei den älteren die am
anfang den stones sind anfang des jahres
wurden wir durch buch inspektionen
erwarten müssen weil diejenigen die am
anfang die eltern mit risikofaktoren die
anfang des jahres gamescom sind die db
sind also ohne dass sie an oster impfung
haben sind durchweg stark gefährdet wenn
wir so wie fasern etwas 73 größe herr
kubicki wenn sie das hören was kallat
rabatte jetzt auf zählt da geht ihnen
doch der puls wahrscheinlich oder ich
werde mir kurz vorm wahnsinn weil kann
auch da war ja auch wissen muss dass
ungefähr zwölf millionen menschen in
deutschland gar keine impfung können
jeweils gegenwärtig bei denen wir dieses
prinzip sie können sich anstecken
weil sie dann dankenswerter weise keine
schweren von läufern ist das hinnehmen
wir schlicht und ergreifend gar nicht
abzuwenden ist denn die müssen am leben
ja immer weiter teilnehmen
meine dänischen freunde und nachbarn
haben sich sicher vor fünf wochen
entschieden dass sie genau dieses
prinzip verfolgen alle über 50 jahren
sind bei ihnen geimpft und für die
menschen die darunter liegen ist es
vergleichbar mit einer mittelschweren
grippe wenn sie überhaupt symptome haben
und deshalb haben sie das öffentliche
leben wieder nahezu vollständig
hergestellt gibt noch einige
einschränkungen öffentlichen
personennahverkehrs mitteln aber
ansonsten ich war gerade in dänemark ist
das öffentliche leben wieder ganz normal
auch die behauptung wir seien mit dem
todesfall zahlen besser durch die gegend
gelaufen als andere vergleichbare länder
hat sich jedenfalls was schweden angeht
als unrichtig herausgestellt über die 18
monate pandemien wird haben die schweden
bezogen auf 100000 einwohner nicht mehr
todesfälle als wir sind am anfang
deutlich mehr todesfälle
das hat deutschland dann im dezember und
januar nachgeholt weil auf die alten und
pflegeheim nicht aufmerksam
sorgsam geachtet worden ist also noch
einmal ich warne vor dramatisierungen
stimme karl lauterbach zu
die pandemie das virus ist gefährlich
wir müssen wege finden damit fertig zu
werden aber die idee der impfung auf der
älteren ist ja nicht dass sie sich nicht
anstecken können sondern dass wenn sie
sich anstecken die verläufe beherrschbar
sind das hab ich nicht mehr schwer sind
ebenfalls keine todesfälle mehr dabei
sind und je mehr menschen sich die impft
haben werden desto weniger spielen die
umkämpfte ungeimpften eine rolle eine
große rolle weil sie sozusagen zum
infektionsgeschehen bei den geimpften
nicht mehr beitragen kann ich habe mich
doch impfen lassen mich selbst zu
schützen und vertraue darauf dass die
impfung auch den schutz gewährleistet
und ich werde mich wahrscheinlich auch
im herbst das dritte mal impfen lassen
um die die vollständig zu erhalten aber
das ist ein eigenvorsorge und wenn
menschen das nicht vor eins hat helge
braun von drei monaten dazu treffend
gesagt der kanzleramtsminister
dann tragen sie ihr risiko für sich
selbst und das soll es dann auch gewesen
sein
ja aber es ist nicht alles ist leider
nicht was dann gewesen ist also wirklich
wichtig jetzt an lasse trage ich nicht
dass ihr risiko für mich allein sondern
ich will dich gefährde auch andere also
ich das ist einfach das problem weil
diese andere andere nicht geimpfte
jahren ja anderen aber das sind auch
menschen auch der nicht geimpft ist
anders sie haben sie haben selbst gesagt
es gibt menschen die sich nicht impfen
lassen können über die 12 millionen sind
definitiv nicht richtig aber das machen
davon ab was es gibt menschen die sich
nicht impfen lassen das sind es 99 109
millionen 9 millionen kinder unter zwölf
die köpfe dies kein impfstoff gibt
momentan es gibt neun millionen kinder
unter zwölf jahren für die es kein
impfstoff gibt dann gibt es schwangere
dass ein ungefähr 600 700.000 jedes jahr
für dies kann im stoff gibt da gibt es
eine ganze menge menschen die können
impfstoff nicht vertragen aus welchen
gründen auch immer
selbst wenn es nur zehn millionen wären
dass menschen die haben noch mal leben
ich hätte sie und ich will hier wirklich
nur korrigieren
es geht nicht um rechthaberei es geht
hier nicht mehr war es mehr und zwar aus
aber es ist tatsächlich so dass ein
impfstoff für die kinder also derzeit
also im tessin ist und ich rechne damit
dass wir diesen oktober zur verfügung
haben werden auch für die junge und die
nase
und der zweite punkt also ist der sie
die also dass für schwangere wird in
großbritannien zu recht im übrigen auf
der grundlage der jetzt kollegen den
studien ausdrücklich also die impfung
empfohlen und ich habe es selbst saß im
fazit ich habe selbst als ebenfalls auch
schwangere geimpft war die studien sagen
ich spricht im prinzip für die impfung
von schwangeren zumindest im zweiten
semester also ich bin keiner der nach
halbe republik nur so zu sagen wann ich
weiß was ich so etwas auch verarbeiten
die gruppe ist ghana bevor wir auch zum
thema impfungen gleich noch kommen
möchte ich einmal mit ihnen beiden über
bilder aus berlin sprechen die wir heute
hier am sonntag erlebt haben eine
querdenker demo die dort stattgefunden
hat teilweise ja schlimme gewaltszenen
auch polizisten die dort gejagt wurden
mehrere hundert festnahmen am ende die
demo war gerichtlich verboten worden am
ende haben die demonstranten dennoch
herr kubicki
machen sie sich sorgen wenn sie diese
bilder sehen glauben sie dass das ganze
noch radikaler werden könnte hier wir
sehen ja auch in frankreich in paris wo
es ausschreitungen gegeben hat erleben
sie da ein neues buch potenzial
ja ich hoffe nicht dass es schlimmer
wird weil ich das für sehr bedenklich
halte und es zeigt mir aber dass die
spaltung in der gesellschaft teilweise
schon so tief ist das normal und
vernünftige kommunikation nicht mehr
stattfindet das was die kritiker machen
ist ja nicht nur darauf hinzuweisen dass
mit bestimmten maßnahmen der korona
bekämpfung politik nicht einverstanden
sind sie bereichen schlicht und
ergreifend recht das kann ich ihnen
gefallen weil mir mir gefallen dass sie
bestimmte an sich nahmen
darauf kommt aber gar nicht an wenn eine
demonstration gerichtlich bestätigt
verboten ist dann muss man sich an
solche regeln halten oder man stellt
institutionen des staates ist insgesamt
in frage ich kann nur dringend davor
warnen auch menschen die sich für mich
aus zu recht gegen korona maßnahme wären
wollen an solchen demonstrationen gegen
ein bestehendes verbot teilzunehmen weil
das den rechtsstaat geschichten der
greif und untergräbt und man kann nicht
behaupten die regierung hält sich ein
rechnung
sätze nicht sondern da muss man schon
sagen warum sie selbst auch in richtung
gesetze halten also macht mir große
sorgen und ich kann nur dafür werben
dass vernunft wieder einkehrt
miteinander redet aber nicht
polizeibeamte jagd oder einen stein aus
geschmerzt kubicki sie sind selbst jude
ist können sie mir erklären warum diese
demo verboten worden ist im vorhinein
und zum beispiel der christopher street
day da haben wir auch bilder vom
vergangenen wochenende wo tausende
zehntausende menschen teilweise oder
vereint sind hier auch ohne maske
marschiert sind da gab es heftige kritik
aber da ist die polizei nicht
eingeschritten
also wird da in gewisser weise mit
zweierlei maß gemessen was
demonstrationen angeht ja es waren
unterschiedliche zeiten denn es gab
keine massen pflicht will die
angeordnete werber der christopher
street day demonstration anders als
jetzt bei der demonstration der
querdenker auch darüber will ich jetzt
gar nicht weiter philosophieren
entscheidend ist nur psychologisch kann
ich nicht beurteilen muss karl
lauterbach sagen ob von den christopher
street day demonstrationen weniger
infektionsgefahr ausgeht als von den
kritiker demonstrationen oder ziel weil
er quer demonstrationen demonstration
ist es ja gerade dokumentieren dass man
sich an staatlicher auflagen ich halten
wir das macht den unterschied aus
das ist auch die begründung der
entscheidung des ovg berlin brandenburg
je gesagt wenn das ziel darin besteht
die linie schutzmaßnahmen gerade nicht
anzuwenden
dann muss man diese demonstration
verbieten weil sie wie gesagt staatliche
anordnung in frage gestellt auf
unzulässige weise in lauterbach wenn sie
diese bilder von der demonstration dort
heute gesehen haben von den quer denken
kann aber eben gleichzeitig auch den
christopher street day vor einer woche
macht ihnen das sorgen
klar das war sorgen
und da muss man auch als epidemiologe
fair sein das eine ist so gefährlich wie
das andere
somit also beide demonstrationen sind
aus meiner sicht also nicht wirklich
also zulassungsfähig gewesen wenn die
stimme aber wolfgang kubicki zu dass
auch sowie gewaltbereitschaft die wir
heute gesehen haben das natürlich
vollkommen unakzeptabel und ich war
gestern also ich bin gestern aus bereich
zuge kommen
da gab es eine ähnliche demonstration
auf
paris dass china europäische bewegung zu
werden also das ist also sich also als
sehr bedenklich an
vor allen dingen weil es sich schlicht
mehr grad fand auch direkt gegen die
stadt wendet das geht zum teil hast du
noch im koma es geht aber zu einem
anderen teil aus und darum auch ganz
gezielt wird also zu demonstrieren gegen
den staat gegen also die gesetze gemacht
werden und die gewaltbereitschaft macht
mir große sorgen aber auf der
christopher street day hätte so nicht
aus meiner sicht dass man persönlich
jetzt und nicht genehmigt werden sollen
also hätte man auch den christopher
street aus ihrer sicht verbieten soll
aus meiner sicht hätte man die dinge
also hätte man den christopher street
day in der größe wurde dann abgelaufen
ist ich also bringer ihren erinnerungen
80.000 teilnehmer als epidemiologe hätte
ich das so für problematisch gefunden
was muss man ehrlicherweise zugeben und
also somit also kann man ihren nicht mit
zweier aus meiner sicht kann man nicht
mit zweierlei maß messen
es kommt hier natürlich zu dazu wird mir
gesagt hat dass also ich dir die
demonstration also gegen die krone
maßnahmen also quasi eine demonstration
war gegen die schutzmaßnahmen die
notwendig sind und beim christopher
street day hat man dagegen nicht der
mostra war sich auch nicht angehalten
somit war es beim christopher street so
dass man schlicht mehr gras sind nicht
gegen die schutzmaßnahmen demonstriert
hat sie aber einfach ignoriert hat und
danach hat man sie einfach ab man
dagegen demonstriert und das was geboten
herr kubicki wenn sie sehen wie viele
menschen unterwegs sind draußen auf der
straße oder bei demonstrationen oder
auch möglicherweise dann im stadion in
den nächsten wochen oder monaten wieder
glauben sie dass wir jetzt alles wieder
öffnen könnten so wie vorher wenn die
menschen sich vernünftig verhalten wo
liegt da ihre grenze kann zunächst
einmal gibt es keine rechtliche
grundlage mehr menschen zu
beeinträchtigen der ausstellung über
grundrechte die genesenen geimpft oder
getestet sind infektionsschutz
gefahrenabwehr und wenn sie
dokumentieren dass aktuell jedenfalls
mit überwiegender wahrscheinlichkeit
von ihnen keine gefahr ausgeht dann darf
man sich auch nicht beschränken in dem
was sie tun
ich hab doch nichts wirklich 80.000
menschen im stadion im fußballstadion
geben gm gfg fgf genesen getestet habe
durch den entsprechenden nachweis
elektronisch auf dem auf ihrem iphone
selbstverständlich für sonst ich hab
damit lag ich habe auch mittlerweile
zweifel daran dass die überlegungen
draußen könnte man sich anstecken
wirklich durchgreifend ist wenn ich die
aerosole forscher in deutschland höre
dann sagen sie das größte problem ist
innenraum ist so ein fahrstühlen wo es
kann durch lüftung gibt wo sich also
längere zeit halten können überall dort
wo ein bisschen wind weht das können die
raucher übrigens auch bestätigen nicht
verschwindet das sofort so dass das hat
er schaue ich mal gesagt
der papst der aerosol forscher in
deutschland übrigens auch bestätigt
jetzt solch universitäre untersuchungen
dass sich im freien schon küssen müssten
damit sie sich anstecken ansonsten waren
masten masken tragen freien relativ
wenig sinn ist müssen die behörden
vielleicht mal darüber nachdenken ob sie
mal wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen
folgen was mich besonders sprachlos
macht das kann karl aber vielleicht
nachvollziehen ist dass die
bundesregierung mir auf meine anfragen
und fdp auf eine kleine anfrage von der
bild zeitung ja auch veröffentlich
bestätigt hat dass sie gar nicht weiß
welche maßnahmen wie wirken und dann
habe ich ein problem damit akzeptiere
dass maßnahme ist werk gesetzt haben bei
denen wir gar nicht wissen ob sie
überhaupt einen beitrag leisten können
zur bekämpfung der pandemie haben wir
überhaupt keine ahnung was wie wirkt in
wahrheit wie gesagt
doch das haben wir schon und zwar wir
orientieren uns an den internationalen
studien die also quasi die ergebnisse
die über das bevor ich das vergessen hat
man hat ja das gefühl dass eine studie
dann die nächste studie und dann gibt's
was läuft die folge am anfang hat man
wirklich wenige studien hatten
eigentlich studiert auf die nächste
studie widerspricht oder komm wieder neu
und so drei vier studien die eine so die
anderen so alles ist sehr
unterschiedlich
wenn man aber ganz viele studien hat wir
haben jetzt wirklich ganz ganz viele
studien dann kann dann die daten aus all
diesen studien zusammenführen und macht
das was man wissenschaftlich eine
metaanalyse
etwashausen ich kriege dann noch gern
gesagt ergebnis und dann kriege ich
wieder ein gutes bild dann wird das
besser und am anfang haben wir wirklich
nicht genug gewusst weil wir wenige
studien hatten die sich dann zum teil
noch widersprochen haben
jetzt wissen wir in italien sehr viel
mehr war diese vielen studien in mit
anna loos und zusammengefasst werden
konnten und bin 1 und satz bevor ich das
vergessen bevor ich hier also an den
alterungsprozess zeige ich wollte auch
sagen
schweden hat eine höhere sterblichkeit
und die weste studie die das zeigt ist
die mieter nach ist die analyse die die
uni tübingen mit der uni jerusalem
gemacht hat in letzter zeit
veröffentlicht da ist die über
sterblichkeit der einzelnen länder sehr
präzis verwischen worden schweden ist
besser gewesen als ich auch vermutet
hatte aber wir haben eine deutlich
geringere über sterblichkeit geschafft
als schweden das noch wichtig mal was
positives zu sein was sonst kriegen die
bürger den eindruck wir beschenken uns
hier ein ohne ende aber es raus aber
lauterbacher kubicki spricht einen
wichtigen punkt an nämlich die frage ob
wir tatsächlich ein schützen können zum
beispiel wie masken uns schützen herr
kubicki finden sie dass man die masken
pflicht wieder abschaffen sollte
jedenfalls im freien öffentlichen raum
in geschlossenen räumen würde ich so
lange nicht die tatsächlich alle von
einem ins angebot auch gebrauch machen
konnten immer noch dafür plädieren in
geschlossenen räumen in masken zu tragen
noch einmal das geht übrigens auch
freiwillig man muss nicht das nicht
anordnen ich selbst weiß er dass dass
ich durch eine maske geschützt werde
wenn der p2 maske tragen habe ich ein
relativ hohen schutz deshalb haben wir
das ja auch eine angeordnete nicht damit
wie andere schützen damit wir uns selbst
schützen und haben entsprechend ihres
alten schweden ja auch herr kubicki ich
will ihn einmal ein foto zeigen
von sebastian kurz in bregenz in einem
theater bei einer veranstaltung hier
sieht man einen raum und dort trägt
keiner maske auch der bundespräsident
nicht wünschen sie sich so etwas auch
bei uns ja selbst wahrscheinlich wünsche
mir so schnell wie möglich die rückkehr
zur normalität das ist übrigens auch
eine verfassungsrechtliche pflicht und
wie gesagt die tatsache dass ja lauter
was sage hat viele studien gelesen und
es gibt jetzt meter studien mit der
studie ninja jurist das ist nichts
anderes als das zusammen schreiben von
verschiedenen studienergebnissen aber
das macht kann er eine eigene neue
schade da raus und wenn man eben drei
wenn man nämlich studie zusammenfasst
bleibt sie aber noch falsch sofern aber
nicht so funktionieren diese studie
nicht
wir können jetzt nicht in die details
der studie ja reingehen weil wir sind ja
nicht beim nächsten sondern bei bild es
ist kam der lauterbacher an doch wegen
einer frage deswegen meine frage was
sebastian kurz da gezeigt hatte war das
jetzt unverantwortlich ist das dann aus
ihrer sicht gefährlich was dort gemacht
wurde
es kommt einfach darauf an ob die leute
die da saßen geimpft gewesen sind und
auch sie mit pcs aber das ist ja ganz
gut aber das bedeutet dann ja wenn man
geimpft genesen getestet wäre macht es
dann auch aus ihrer sicht eigentlich
gibt es dann keinen grund dort mit maske
zu sitzen oder also in einem innenraum
ich meine dieser raum ist natürlich sehr
voll
also ich habe ausdrücklich davon
gesprochen dass dann der test mit dem
bcr gemacht sagen muss also mit also
allein mit dem schnauzer ist mit
dramatik geht es würde wären wir das zu
gefährlich aber man muss der erörterung
auf ihre stars zurück zu kommen also
wenn es so ist das also in einen großen
raum wo leute relativ nahe beieinander
sind nur menschen sind die geimpften und
damit ganze findet was bringt es uns
verlieren die also geimpft sind genesen
sind oder mit einen pcr-test sind dann
hätte ich auch so in innenräumen ohne
maske kein problem wenn das die
voraussetzungen sind also was ist mit
schulen zum beispiel also die kinder
müssen immer noch im schulunterricht
stunden lang dort mit masken sitzen was
für viele eine große beeinträchtigung
ist das problem ist also und werden und
gibt das unternehmen ist was wir also
erstens sind die kinder mit also schnell
fest getestet von den positiven zimmer
10 positiven ist leider der schnelltest
in vier von zehn fällen negativ somit
ist das problem also das fest nicht ist
nicht gut genug wenn das jetzt der
lolita ist beispielsweise ist und er
würde gemacht bevor die kinder in die
schule kommen das wäre dann wäre es dann
ganz anders sieht was du warst eine
wichtige frage die sich stellen war
tatsächlich wenn wir zur normalität
zurückkommen wollen sozusagen geimpft
genesen und getestet dann müssen wir
viel mehr pcr tests machen schnell dass
es gibt auch sehr schnell hat bz er ist
immer laufen kann oder gruppenbild
gebote pcr das weil den dieser
kombination also pcr test also games und
genießen kann dann andere extrem hohe
sicherheit darstellen als sehr hohe
sicherheit
herr kubicki das ist einfach wunderbar
es ist genau meine position da müssten
wir doch alles dafür tun als politische
entscheidungsträger eine solche
situation so schnell wie möglich
herzustellen und nicht zu warten
warum warum warten wir monate warum
besorgen wenn ich dafür das beispiel in
allen schulen diese lolita umgesetzt
werden
warum sorgen wenn ich dafür dass überall
dort wo genesene geimpfte und von mir
aus auch pc schnell getestete und
unterwegs sind die keine beschränkung
mehr tragen müssen weil es dafür oft es
kann keine rechtliche grundlage geben
noch einmal von denen geht keine gefahr
aus oder keine signifikante gefahr aus
deshalb darf man sie in ihr
bewegungsraum in dem was sie tun indem
die sie ihr leben gestalten auch nicht
mehr beschränken
diese kombination geimpft genießende und
pch getestete kann man sehr viel sich
leisten kann man sehr viel leugnen
und bevor ich das vergesse ich habe auch
immer dafür plädiert dass in den
außenräumen im prinzip die maske riller
ich wenig bringt also wenn ich dann also
halten wir fest erstaunlicherweise sind
bei dem punkt einer meinung
deswegen wollen wir schnell weiter macht
hat sich heute abend hat sich wie damen
hat sich für mich schon gelohnt haben
wir das theater war meiner meinung ist
insofern war schon toll
wir waren wir waren der gleichen meinung
wer jetzt verlauten möchte zu einem
weiteren punkt kommen sie haben sie
haben gerade gesagt dass sie aus
frankreich zurück gekommen sind das
heißt für sie gar wahrscheinlich die
neue testpflicht die seit heute gilt
bislang noch nicht richtig oder wie
haben sie das wahrgenommen wie sie da
ausdrücklich ich bin ich bin einen tag
also bevor die testpflicht würde ich
mich selbst auch eingesetzt hatte also
zum tragen gekommen ist genau so ist es
wie nehmen sie das wahr wie das heute
funktioniert hat und ob es funktioniert
hat weil was wir hören aus allen
regionen ist das dass man dass er
ähnliche wirklich kontrollieren kann
also von dem was ich bisher gehört habe
hat es nicht ganz so schlecht
funktioniert das so wenn man so will
also erweiterte schleierfahndung in
bayern von dem was ich gehört habe ich
wie gesagt nicht vor ort gewesen aber
leider etwas schleier verhandlungen im
zusammenhang mit urlaubsrückkehrern also
da dreht sich mir so ein bisschen der
magen um habe ich sagen ja das ist doch
es geht doch darum was ich nenne ich
nenne die dinge gerne aus aber ich nenne
die dinge gerne wahrnahmen und du hast
nutzt das wenn man das mit anderen
euphemismus net umschalt wenn es aber
ich brauch genau das ist hier wird was
sie nach urlaubern gefahren wird die
also ohne test ins land kommen wollen
und die will man nicht was soll das dann
anders sagen was einer steuerfahndung
herr kubicki
wie erleben sie das wenn jetzt wieder
die polizei kontrolliert wenn familien
aus dem urlaub zurück kommen dabei
wissen wir dass der auslandsanteil bei
den gemeldeten neuinfektionen lediglich
bei zwölf prozent lag in den vergangenen
wochen also bedeutet 88 prozent der
infektionen fanden in deutschland statt
ist das ist das ist das übertrieben
definitiv mehr sage ich ganz klar warum
das jetzt angehört worden ist zum ersten
august wohl bei den meisten
bundesländern die ferien zu ende sind
wir noch zwei bundesländer baden
württemberg und bayern die jetzt in die
ferien gehen möglicherweise markus söder
seine landsleute nicht oder trauten sich
das nicht zu da sind menschen in urlaub
gefahren kommen zurück und hatten gar
nicht mehr die chance
im ausland da wo sie waren ein
entsprechendes vornehmen zu lassen und
die jetzt mit
ordnungswidrigkeitenverfahren bußgeldern
zu belegen halte ich auch so aus
rechtsstaatlichen gründen für für
inakzeptabel bleibt unabhängig von der
kontrolle möglichkeit die wir insgesamt
haben es ist wieder ein baustellen da
wir haben deutschland incidents jetzt
von 17,5 von mir so 18 ist egal wieder
ein baustein der die menschen sorge und
auch angst machen soll und ihnen nicht
gut machen soll doch für ihren eigenen
schutz zu sorgen
ich will darauf hinweisen kann auch
danach wird mir vielleicht folgen können
das infektionsschutzgesetz eigentlich
unterhalb party dance von 35 gar keine
grundriss beschränkende maßnahmen
erlaubt es sei denn es besteht die
unmittelbare gefahr diese 35er incident
zahl zu reißen
da wir mittlerweile wissen dass die
institute selbst west pandemie geschehen
nur eine wirklich geringe aussagekraft
hat müssen wir mal darüber nachdenken
diesen wert auch anzupassen bei der
frage wie beurteilen wir eigentlich die
voraussetzungen für grundrechts
einschränkungen ich bin jetzt gerade im
europapark rust und höre dass schweizer
und französische gäste die er hier nur
ein paar kilometer entfernt sind nicht
mehr einreisen das fatale
wirtschaftliche folgen hat weil bei
denen der eindruck erzeugt worden ist
wenn sie die deutsche grenze
überschreiten auch wenn sie auch nur für
wenige stunden machen müssen sich einem
entsprechenden test unterziehen also man
sollte vielleicht müssen intensiver auch
mal nachdenken über die folgen solcher
entscheidungen
anstatt sich einfach nur hinzunehmen
lauterbach und insbesondere betroffen
sind wieder mal die kinder die ja
bislang sich eben nicht impfen können
und jetzt alle familien die mit kindern
zurückkehren müssen erst mal getestet
werden was ist eigentlich können sie das
beantworten wenn man dann im auto sitzt
und positiv getestet wurde kurz bevor
man nach hause kommen wollte dann ein
kind zum beispiel kroner positiv ist man
fährt nach hause und gehen konnten
das ist die situation und dann kann man
froh sein dass quasi die also diagnose
gestellt worden ist so dass man also
dafür sorgen kann dass es genauso gut
versorgt ist und das ist kein anderes
ansteckt aber anders geht es natürlich
nicht
ich glaube nicht dass die maßnahme angst
macht oder willkürlich ist wir haben im
letzten jahr ja auch gezogen haben der
fälle
durch die rückkehrer aus den
urlaubsgebieten beobachten müssen und
wir wollen das ist dann halt unterlegt
wurden herr lauterbach also dass die
urlaubsrückkehrer im letzten jahr die
infektions treiber gewesen sind dafür
gibt es überhaupt keine belege
es ist nicht wichtig also nicht ich hab
nicht da so von infektions treibern
gesagt infektion stripe hat sich ja
immer so als wenn das die haupt dass das
ist die wichtigste quelle gewesen werden
also von denen dann ist es ausgehen die
abends angetriebenen alle anderen lagen
nicht wichtig aber es war halt ein
wichtiger faktor und das war's im
letzten jahr wird auch dieses jahr
wieder sein
somit kämpfen wir einfach da für die
fallzahlen so niedrig zu halten wie geht
bis zum herbst und wir versuchen eben
also mehr impfungen auch ins braucht was
läuft immer auf die gleiche grundfrage
aus wenn man also sowieso der meinung
ist dass man die hände einfach schlicht
der krankheit überlässt dass man sagt
okay der rest kann sich jetzt infizieren
dass durch solche wieder war es für die
entweder nicht schwimmen also nicht
schlimm verläuft oder war sie selbst
schuld sind wenn ich dich so sag mal den
kaffee wenn ich so denke dann kann ich
mir wirklich vieles vorstellen aber
hätte die das terrassenfenster gesamte
zelt muss den weg machen nicht notwendig
aber es sind auch aus dem bereich 130
fälle gewesen am tag lediglich es sind
jetzt eben der fälle die zurückkommen
jeder einer delta fahrrad an erklärt ist
eine quelle für also fünf weitere fälle
auf den grundlagen des nennwertes den
wir haben
wir wollen einfach vermeiden dass die
fahrzeuge ansteigen
die leute kommen zum teil aus ländern wo
ist das sehr viel höher als bei uns und
haben viele kontakte gab wenn es so ist
dass es tatsächlich weniger fälle sind
dann werden wir es ja demnächst sehen
aber ich befürchte dass es anders ist
herr kubicki wenn sie das hören auch was
er lauterbach sagt und den engen
austausch ist mit dem vizekanzler aber
auch mit der kanzlerin
was die korona politik der regierung
angeht ich hab da so ein bisschen das
gefühl da könnte in den nächsten wochen
oder monaten noch ein ganz neuer hammer
drohen und wir wieder zumindest in einer
lockdown dann für diejenigen gehen die
nicht geimpft sind oder wie nehmen sie
das war ja verschiedene maßnahmen
scheinen mir nicht ganz logisch wenn
lotta war sagt wenn jemand getestet ist
im ausland und sich infiziert hatte da
darf man nach hause fahren und sich dort
in quarantäne begeben
viel spannender wie das dann doch
gewesen den leuten angebot zu machen
wenn sie die deutsche grenze
überschreiten dass sie dort in einem
zelt gehen können um sich testen lassen
können als von ihnen zu erwarten dass im
ausland erstmal verschiedene städte
aufsuchen überhaupt ein labor zu finden
was sie entsprechend erst ab nimmt also
menschen zur ordnungswidrigkeit opfern
zu machen die sich im ausland haben
testen können aber sie müssen nach hause
das finde ich ziemlich verwerflich den
muss man dann sagen leute werden nach
hause fahrt geht nun ein test ran und
lasst euch testen
dann ist das hat das sein bewenden was
ich befürchte ist nicht dass das diese
bundesregierung so lange sie im amt ist
und auch einige landesregierungen
solange sie im amt sind versuchen die
korona politik der vergangenen wochen
und monate zu rechtfertigen weil
verschiedene maßnahmen werk gesetzt
worden sind die sich als nicht
durchschlagend diesen noch einmal klar
carlotta noch nicht nur nicht dass
masken im freundlich gar nicht zu
bringen und trotzdem müssen wir an
verschiedenen orten in einigen städten
sogar in fußgängerzonen oder masken
tragen wenn wir zum einkaufen gehen also
ich befürchte das festhalten an der
reinen incidents teil würden
schwierigkeiten bereiten weil wir sehen
werden dass gerade bei jüngeren die
incidents zahlen nach oben gehen werden
kann oder kann nicht reagieren habe ich
das richtig im kopf halber letzte rk ii
aussage ist die inzidenz bei den über
50-jährigen unter 5 also weniger als
fünf menschen auf 100000 einwohner bei
den über 15 sind infiziert das ist eine
größenordnung wo wir früher gesagt
hätten gott sei dank die pandemie ist
vorbei wenn wir ins hohe inzidenz zahl
haben bei den unter 30 jährigen ist das
war ein signal möglicherweise auch dort
wo hotspot sein können aber es ist nicht
mehr besorgniserregend denn noch einmal
die lernaufgabe war die keine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems das
allein rechtfertigt die maßnahme mehr
feststellen
eine überlastung des gesundheitssystems
droht nicht mehr dann müssen wir
jedenfalls die maßnahmen die bisher
beschränkungen beinhalteten aufheben
aber bevor ich das tor noch
daraufhin lassen werden sich jetzt
jemand im ausland das infiziert hat und
macht dort den test dann kann er nicht
zum beispiel mit öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln und dergleichen zurück
fahren oder fliegen was natürlich klar
ich war eben den mann war gerade zu
einem auto gegangen und warte darauf
dass er im auto unterwegs gewesen ist
nur dass sie das leben die menschen
denen es hier zu hören dass ich im
falschen habe ich kann nicht wenn ich
jetzt mich infiziert habe in madrid
wegen in paris kann ich mich nicht in
den zug setzen und sarah dann zurück und
so das geht nicht
aber hier zu der frage also die die
fallzahlen sind niedrig und so weiter
das problem ist noch dass -folgen ich
hoffe dass wir das bald in den griff
bekommen also ich kenne ja dafür und
hoffe auf also und glaube auch dass wir
die herdenimmunität schaffen aber wenn
wir wandern etwas siedlungseinheiten
immunität dann werden wir das schaffen
und nach werden die mobilität also liegt
hier bei ungefähr 85 prozent ich habe
heute war in dem blatt gelesen und auf
der seite gelesen also von einem
wissenschaftler der davon ausgeht dass
ist niedriger werden
und da dachte ich und so dass der diesel
also berechnungen teile ich nicht also
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass wir an
schließlich also der kinder habe ich die
mit borussia als wir dann an der
herdenimmunität erreichen eine 85
prozent haben aber alle retten oder zu
konzerten sagen das ist gar nicht
realistisch das ist nicht erreichbar
kann ich kann ist sehr schön ich da wird
das sind wir eben unterschiedliche
meinungen gebe nicht auf dem mist ich
glaube das ist reich war also dass ich
bin hier wirklich da ich glaube erstens
dass hier kommunität so hoch liegt von
380 prozent also dass man dass wir nicht
hinkommen mit 75 prozent oder so geht es
bei ihnen heute also im blatt stand
sondern dass wir so hoch müssten 85%
unserem 2
ich glaube auch das nicht schaffen
werden aber wir müssen auch noch einmal
wir müssen uns noch einmal klären um auf
85 prozent zu kommen bei lauterbad dann
müssten sich alle erwachsene impfen plus
anteile jugendlichen wie realistisch
sondern seien klar ist dass stadt und
ihr hinterland anschauen oder infizierte
ja dass ich glücklich ich glaube dass
ich das im herbst also schlicht
verändert wird also zunächst also ich
glaube dass bis zum herbst nicht dick
endlich also die position verändert
haben wird und auch die info
bis 17-jährigen empfehlen was war was
macht man nicht normale so viele länder
in den vereinigten staaten
beispielsweise jahren damit so viel
erfahrung schon und das sind so dermaßen
gute wissenschaftler die dort die
regierung beraten also das sind absolute
qualität also zur universität dahinter
ich glaube dass also wir uns hier
bewegen werden so dass die kinder
ebenfalls also gm fällt zum zweiten also
bei denjenigen die bisher nicht games
sind bei den erwachsenen wird es so sein
natürlich ist es so die erwachsenen
müssen
herr kubicki hat ist ja eben auch schon
eingeräumt wenn wir die gleich behandeln
wollen dann brauchen wir für sie pcr
test und diesen zirkus regelmäßig sich
den spezies zu besorgen und
beispielsweise eine also diskothek zu
besuchen oder den innenraum der
innenraum veranstaltung was wäre die
leute nicht mitmachen wollen
die werden dann sich eher impfen lassen
somit glaube ich wird im herbst werden
die situation klar wird dass will
innenräumen für die nicht geimpften
einschränkungen haben
und wenn die kinder geht sind werden wir
schon 80 prozent schaffen
also machen sie dann druck auf nicht
geimpfte indirekt das bestimmte dinge
nicht mehr besucher sind zum beispiel im
kino oder das restaurant dann nur noch
für geimpfte oder getestete aber noch
mal die frage weil wir gerade bei dem
thema wandern einfach das wasser ist
druck das ist einfach ein gebot der
ehrlichkeit ich darf die also menschen
die dort sitzen nicht gefährden und
daher muss ich gesetzt haben
was mich interessiert eher lauterbach
und das ist ja die debatte geführt wird
hier in den vergangenen wochen und herr
kubicki hat es angesprochen warum
schauen sie zum beispiel immer noch so
sehr auf den incidents wert warum ist
das immer noch so an neidfaktor und wie
hoch ist aus ihrer sicht oder wie wie
hoch kann die incident sein dass sie uns
nicht gefährlich wird also ich stimme
lothar wieler zu dass der incidence
fährt eben super interessantes wichtig
ist nicht dass er weniger wert
aber wenn ich den incidence mit habe von
heute und die altersverteilung der also
menschen die also jetzt also sich
angesteckt haben
dann weiß ich doch alles andere was
danach kommt im prinzip also
ergebnis geben uns in mehreren incidents
wert und die altersverteilung dann kann
ich ihnen sagen wie viele also
krankenhausfälle wir in 14 tagen haben
werden davon lässt sich doch alles
andere ableiten ich kann sagen wie viele
leute wahrscheinlich
tja und werden wir sehen wir sehen ja
dass der inzidenz wirkt steigt in
einigen ländern und die hospitalisierung
rate eben nicht und das vor allem auch
die todesfälle das recht als überrascht
nicht ja gar nicht auswendig die wenn
ich den residenz wert sie erzählt dass
die leute sich das infiziert haben dass
die dose dann gehe ich davon aus wird
die aus spezialisierung kaum ansteigen
aber ich warne davor das beispiel
england zu bringen weil hinter zahlen
dass dort die institute stark gestiegen
das ist auch die also krankenhaus
anpassungs quote gestiegen aber
geschenkt also wenn ich die inzidenz
bekomme und sehe das sehr junge leute
dann war es nicht da wird niemanden ins
krankenhaus gehen an kubicki wie hoch
kann in deutschland die inzidenz sein
dass uns das völlig egal ist wo sehen
sie da die grenze ist grenzenlos 200 sie
denen man kann den sie dance glaube ich
jetzt von 290 das interessiert überhaupt
nicht weil das dach das er je nachdem in
welcher altersgruppe leiters konnte das
passiert kann lauterbacher recht wir
müssen uns sorgen machen wenn die wenn
die inzidenz bei den über bei den über
50 jeder auf eine größenordnung von 500
von 50 oder 100 hoch geht da müssen wir
uns sorgen machen wir wieder genau
wissen je älter desto größer die
wahrscheinlichkeit für schwere verläufe
und für todesfälle
je jünger das will ja die
wahrscheinlichkeit für schwerer verläufe
und todesfälle insofern sagt die
inzidenz was das panini geschehen an
geht jetzt nicht mehr sehr viel aus aber
ich möchte ich gerne auf einen punkt
kommt beim ich das doch ziemlich
ziemlich anfasst wir haben eine ständige
impfkommission die unabhängig ist und
die empfehlung geben abgeben soll fürs
impfen die ihr kann sich bisher nicht
dazu durchringen das impfen
uneingeschränkt zu empfehlen für zwölf-
bis 17-jährige morgen will die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz beschließen
eine politisches gremium
gesundheitsminister von denen
wahrscheinlich keiner wirklich arzt ist
wir entscheiden das auf zwölf bis 17
jährigen wieder studien woher auch immer
aber wenn wir eine unabhängige
kommission haben die dass die das
beurteilen soll
dann ist der verstoß gegen eine solche
empfehlung ein möglicherweise eine
straftat jeder arzt der gegen eine nicht
voran der empfehlung der stiko impft
haftet für die für die impfschäden die
möglicherweise daraus resultieren und
ich kann nur dringend davor warnen von
denen der regeln die wir uns gegeben mit
dieser frage abzuweichen
es kann nicht sein dass es einmal den
wissenschaftlern den sollen folgen unter
anderem wenn die wissenschaft und nicht
weiß uns politischen kram passt aber
noch einmal ich bin der letzte der ich
habe davon keine ahnung bin der letzte
der radschläger teil will ich sagen nur
als jurist ich warne vor falschen
schlussfolgerungen und ich empfehle
tatsächlich auch die empfehlungen der
stiko zu werden dagegenhalten also 2
ich werde hier keine politische
positionierung gegen die stiko vortragen
war das bin ich auch was aber wäre
sowieso ein argument wir haben minister
beschließen sollen die das beschließen
aus ihrer sicht wir werden das
wahrscheinlich beschließen aber lassen
sie mich aus wir uns zunächst andere was
ich bin
so las ich sozusagen denke bevor wir
dann zu der frage kommen habe ich
irgendjemanden kritisieren muss sich
also ich bin als wissenschafter davon
überzeugt dass die zurückhaltung der
stiko was die impfung von 12 bis 17
jährigen angeht nicht richtig ist die
studienlage gibt das her und ich dicke
wartet hier auf langfrist daten die es
nie geben wird
wir wissen also aus anderen
zusammenhängen dass also schwere
nebenwirkungen bei impfungen sehr früh
kommen die amerikaner haben mittlerweile
sechs millionen impfungen also gemacht
bei kindern
es sind keine wesentlichen also
unbekannten gravierenden nebenwirkungen
aufgetreten und die delta variante hat
durch solche variante mehr für die
kinder so viel sehr viel gefährlicher
daher bin ich der meinung dass die stiko
hier irrt aber ich bin nicht der meinung
dass man politischen druck auf die stiko
ausüben sollte und ein einsatz noch ein
publikum
ich habe auch also kinder geimpft zum
beispiel auch mal etwas riskiert dagegen
die empfehlung handelt genau das wollte
ich das sage ich wenn ich also wenn ich
etwas aufklärung
11 wenn das kind geimpft werden will und
ich kläre die eltern auf und also machen
dann die impfung dann ist es rechtlich
vollkommen unerheblich ob die stiko
dafür und dagegen der vorgang
das hat rechtlich überhaupt keine
konsequenz wenn ich nach venedig nach
wenn ich nach besten wissen also und
bester medizinischer kunst auf der
grundlage dessen was ein
wissenschaftlich also gesichert ist
einen zugelassenen impfstoff also einen
auch in deutschland zugelassenen
impfstoff nach aufklärung verwendet dann
ist es kein problem also daher machen
das ja auch ärzte mit mir angefangen
dann ist es kein problem dass ich auch
ohne stiko empfehlung info ich bin
trotzdem der meinung dass das pico dass
die stiko zurückhaltend problematisch
ist aber recht ich bringe mich dass ich
kein problem
kubicki wenn wir uns das anschauen der
druck der da jetzt ausgeübt wird hier
haben ja auch noch mal die schlagzeile
der bild am sonntag von heute nämlich
genau zu dem thema wo es um die
impfpflicht für und nicht die
impfpflicht das impfen für zwölfjährige
angeht und das was morgen passiert herr
kubicki wenn sie sich das anschauen ist
dass am ende was gerade diskutiert wird
eine impfpflicht durch die hintertür
naja allein allein der druck die
aufgebaut wird dass menschen die nicht
geimpft sind am normalen
gesellschaftlichen leben nicht
teilnehmen können ist schon eine
drohkulisse die viele beeindrucken wird
und ich sage noch einmal das ist ja
wahrscheinlich der sinn der
veranstaltung war versprochen dass
gesetzlich nicht vorzuschreiben dass
sich jeder impfen lassen muss und
deshalb wird der soziale druck erhöht
und es sollte alles fertig erklärt auch
die tests werden künftig nicht mehr
bezahlt wobei ich das ziemlich komisch
finde weil die impfung die auch bezahlt
wird also ist eben gesagt so viele
männer sie gar nicht es ist nämlich
durch die hintertür selbstverständlich
na ja so sehe ich es nicht also es ist
medizinisch einfach schlicht und
ideologisch begründet also ich kann halt
die ich kann halt medizinisch wird
ideologisch in einem innenraum
beispielsweise wenn also die fahrzeit
kann ich den also nicht games nicht so
war
aber er laut aber was ist was ist davon
übrigen am 7 das dass die politik oder
die regierung an der die spd beteiligt
ist den deutschen versprochen hat dass
es keine impfpflicht geben wird und wenn
man sich die diskussion anschaut dies
vor einem jahr zum beispiel gehabt genau
zu dem thema dann hat sich das doch sehr
verändert wir hören auch was der patch
man in baden württemberg gesagt hat wir
hören was markus söder sagt was
mitglieder der bundesregierung sagen
alle machen druck auf die menschen dass
sich impfen soll das wenn ich also an
die menschen die nicht gehend sind
appelliere bitte für so etwas anderes ob
sie sagen dürfen dann machen wir das
restaurant zum beispiel ja aber dass das
nicht das ist doch ganz klar wie will
ich denn da vorgehen wenn jetzt der
herbst kommt
wir können nicht mehr draußen setzen
kleines restaurant ich habe gestern
abend meine tochter so in einem
italiener draußen gesessen
wenn jetzt die leute die erste nationale
in den innenraum sind ist doch ganz klar
in da also mit einer schnauze es
beispielsweise getestet werden wenn da
32 leute drin sind also die positiv sind
und wurde schnelltest also entweder fans
negativ ist oder ist gar nicht wichtig
gemacht worden war nur dass die ersten
zwei millimeter der nase also benutzt
worden sind
die leute gefährden uns doch alle dass
das will doch niemand ich will das auch
nicht ich will nicht dass ich wenig
gefährdet werden also mit durchbruch
varianten
ich will nicht dass die uhr so anderen
gefährdet werden nur weil leute nicht
bereit sind sich helfen zu lassen die
müssen dann zumindest akzeptiert dass
bestimmte einschränkungen für siege was
ist so ganz war er noch an
das geht doch nicht um sie selbst ging
der objektiven britta wie was wäre ihre
lösung stich verstehe ich fürchte ich
werde ich verstehe die ich verstehe die
logik nicht ganz denn ich bin hier
aufgefordert worden aber ich habe hier
selbst aufgefordert mich impfen zu
lassen damit ich für ungeimpften oder
vor infektionen keine angst mehr haben
muss bei claas die impfung schützt mich
nicht vor infektionen schützen nicht nur
vor einem schweren verlauf und
möglicherweise einem todesfall so ich
weiß nicht warum geimpft
sich sorgen machen müssen über
ungeimpfte umgeben wird sie
möglicherweise sorgen darüber ungeimpfte
aber die haben sich selbst entschieden
dass sich nicht impfen lassen das heißt
die tragen das risiko mein risiko so
dankenswerterweise durch die impfung sei
es bisher verstanden deutlich minimiert
worden und wenn ich die logik von herrn
lothar übertragen wurde auch das
allgemeine leben
dann müssten wir uns zwar für alle
verpflichtenden dass wir
grippeschutzimpfungen jedes jahr über
uns ergehen lassen weil wir
logischerweise uns überall sonst auch an
stecken übrigens auch teilweise mit
schweren verläufen mit todesfällen
es gibt noch andere an das
infektionsgeschehen wo wir dann die
überlegung kamen müssten
jeder muss sich dann impfen lassen um
andere die sich nicht die nebensaison
nicht haben davor zu bewahren dass sie
erkranken also die logik herr lauterbach
war dohr wir lassen uns alle impfen weil
wir dann ausschließen können jeweils in
aller regel schwerer verläufe und
todesfälle sagt habe ich wenn ich in der
kneipe gehe ja das ist die 5 ungeimpfte
schon gar keine sorge mehr denn ich bin
ja ich werde erstmal sehr gute nase sehr
sehr guter grund also einfach unbenommen
sehr guter punkt trotzdem mal so sehe
ich es anders und wird es auch von den
maßen wissenschaftlern anders gesehen
und sondern auf der grundlage wenn ihr
es meinetwegen in diese knallt geburt
also da gestern war genau gesagt ich
dagegen hatte wird sich ärgern wenn ich
sage was zeichnen aber wenn da jetzt mal
entwickeln also fünf ungeimpfte sind die
assets mit gefährden sich ja gegenseitig
und somit ist sozusagen also machte ich
auch der ungeimpften muss geschützt
werden also ich muss dir und lebensmut
unter einander stützen sich einfach
sagen die sind selbst schuld
eigentlich lieben aber ein herr lauda
der topf nicht verliebt und bin ich auch
nicht doch nicht wir haben jedoch nicht
gegen ihn habe dagegen gehen will die
entscheidend auch selbst nicht gehen
jetzt schützen
wenn ich also würde keinen sinn machen
richtig karriere auch dafür
mit dem also logik die aus so wie er die
zeit gefahren sind verhindern wir dass
menschen sich gegenseitig gefährden
auch zum beispiel auf der demo die wir
eben gesehen haben das sind ja alles
querrey
wenn ich so argumentiert könnte ich
sagen wenn sie sich das selbst gefährden
und infiziert und sich das ist auch
nicht mein problem
wir machen das ja frage liegt aber die
will haben mit dem mädchen immer
geschützt
selbst die die vollkommen rücksichtslos
waren die also von den crooner
maßnahmenmix garten haben denen ist in
wirklichkeit egal war auf stufe 2 und
somit wenn ich dann in den usa auf fünf
ungeschickt und also hier in habe ist
das halt ein problem das die sich
gegenseitig gefährt ich will ihnen und
demnächst kommt noch das problem mit den
durch einen satz hallo herr gelegen
trotzdem bat ich ihn vorgehen schützen
herr kollege lauterbach das ist
zutreffend so lange ist kein impfstoff
gab es lange nicht jeder geben fern
konnte jetzt kann jeder geben völlig
plädiere auch dafür dass ich möglichst
viele menschen impfen lassen
aber die leute sich impfen lassen wollen
die tragen ein eigenes risiko um das mal
auch auf einen anderen bereich zu
bringen wir haben jedes jahr zwischen 20
und 40 tausend tote in den kliniken
wegen kinderheimen und trotzdem kommt
von uns kann noch auf die idee dass die
geschützt werden müssen die
krankenhäuser zu machen verstehen sie
wenn wenn da ich den film dankenswerter
weise kann ich nur sagen leute lasst
euch erleben und dann müsst ihr selbst
keine chance mehr haben vor den drei
vier fünf leuten die euch möglicherweise
als infizierte begegnen weil ihr
dankenswerterweise durch den impfschutz
jetzt davor geschützt werden schwere
verläufe und todesfälle nach sich ziehen
zu müssen zu haben ich will in beiden
arbeit zeigen was hubert aiwanger der
vize ministerpräsident von bayern in der
auseinandersetzung zum impfen gesagt hat
entscheidung ob sich jemand impfen lässt
oder nicht ist eine persönliche
entscheidung die nehme ich auch für mich
in anspruch und die lautet eben dass ich
mich bisher nicht dazu entscheiden
konnte mich impfen zu lassen
heißt nicht dass ich mich generell
niemals impfen lassen werde ich schaue
mir einfach die entwicklung jetzt deinen
nächsten wochen und monaten an
und ich glaube auch wir sollten keinen
öffentlichen druck aufbauen das gilt
jetzt gar nicht in erster linie für mich
auch menschen die vom hilfen für sich
als person noch nicht überzeugt sind es
gilt für schüler das gilt für diverse
berufsgruppen und altersklassen
wir sollten hier nicht sagen du ag ist
falsch weil du dich noch nicht raus
impfen lassen es ist eine persönliche
entscheidung und dabei sollten wir es
belassen
herr kubicki hat herr aiwanger recht
in der sache hat er recht trotzdem würde
ich mir fehlen war ja neben skepsis auch
verbreitet er hat sich ja noch zu nicht
durchringen können würde ich nur
empfehlen da mal intensiver nachzudenken
politiker sowie lauterbach und ich und
andere aber auch eine vorbildfunktion
und wenn wir glauben ich glaube dass
tatsächlich dass der impfschutz mich
davor bewahrt schwer zu erkranken
dann sollte man den menschen wie gesagt
auch durch eigene im foto kommentieren
dass man diesen glauben hat und dass man
dieses vertrauen hat dass man durch die
impfung weniger schäden potenzielle
leitet als durch hier nicht impfung laut
aber wie nehmen sie das wahr was da
gerade passiert in bayern zwischen den
anfänger und markus söder
also ich empfinde er als eine einzige
figur in dieser also debatte weil er
ständig vor dass er noch abwarten
also wie sichere impfstoff denn sein und
das ist natürlich eine groteske
positionierung weil sie sich gegen die
etablierte wissenschaft also weltweit
stellt wir haben noch nie an in dem
stoff was so sei es so kalt eingesetzt
und so gut untersucht
wie also die sowie dessen stoffe und
daher habe ich schlicht und ergreifend
also nicht die phantasie mir
vorzustellen worauf er hier wartet um
seine entscheidung zu treffen
und wenn wir schon so positioniert ist
dann stehe ich
wolfgang kubicki ausdrücklich zu wir
sind ja als politiker exponierte
politiker sind wir ob wir das wollen
oder nicht in einer vorbildfunktion wenn
das schon seine ich sage mal peinliche
positionierung ist dann sollte er sich
nicht für sich behalten und nicht
öffentlich darüber reden war eher
verunsichert menschen erst krisen
widerspricht sagt limberger ja nicht an
ich will auch so nicht ansprechbar vor
dass ich appelliere nur ansagen verstand
was es geht es ja kein verbot nicht
nicht die sagen wir reden nur ich
verbiete ihm ja nix das wäre das ist ja
ein unterschied
ich will ja dass er selbst einmal
dahinter kommt dass das nicht die
richtige art ist erst nicht klar das ist
aber sehr pädagogisch
das funktioniert nur bei leuten die
nature lesen glaub ich 11 na ja also es
kann sportmanager aber eben schon von
profitiert dass er ein nichtmitglied das
ist mir klar aber also trotzdem also
wenn ich eine kontroverse position in
anderen wichtigen frage haben für mich
selbst und weiß dass das sagen wir die
öffentlichkeit verunsichern könnte dann
ist es besser wenn man schweigen ich hab
sogar den eindruck dass es sich ein
bisschen politik hier sogar ich leute
mal ins rechte lager ausdehnen will
richtung hfc oder was auch immer war das
was er vorträgt bissig oder der kubicki
kennt den beste hat sich vielleicht
durch ihnen damit auch unrecht auf jeden
fall ist das alles in allem also ein
peinlicher vorgang
herr kubicki sollte sich das von herrn
eifel hat rennen ist quatsch also ich
kenne ein alter überhaupt nicht ich kann
nur sondern seine argumentation ich sage
noch einmal in der sache hat er recht
und allein die tatsache dass wir
politisch diskutieren kann der
vize-chefin bayern bleiben bestehen oder
minister bleiben kann er
wirtschaftsminister bleiben dokumentiert
hier dass wir einen faktischen einen
faktischen eine faktische impfpflicht
sollen sozusagen ins leben rufen weil
wenn er sagen würde ich lasse mich jetzt
nicht eben für aus welchen gründen auch
immer
dann wird er nicht mehr tauglich wieder
das amt ich sage nur er muss bei seinen
individuellen schade auch mal darüber
nachdenken dass eine person des
öffentlichen lebens ist und das sollte
ihm dann tatsächlich auch ein bisschen
zu denken geben aber noch einmal er kann
in der sache sich entscheiden wie er
will er kann das sagen was er für
richtig hält
ich teile seine auffassung nicht aber
ich akzeptiere sie zum abschluss
interessiert mich eine frage und auch
unsere zuschauer interessiert diese
frage immens wie es in den nächsten
wochen nächsten monaten weiter geht
viele haben so ein bisschen das gefühl
es gibt ja gerade ein déjà vu
und jetzt gehen dann bald wieder in
einigen bundesländern die schulen los
aber so richtig funktioniert da auch
immer noch nichts vielleicht dann doch
wieder wechsel unterricht was passiert
in den betrieben wie geht es weiter mit
den kulturveranstaltungen
herr kubicki fangen mit ihnen an wenn
sie sich anschauen die kanzlerin bleibt
noch im amt bis mindestens herbst je
nachdem wie die koalitions diskussion
mit ihnen dann vielleicht am tisch
wie intensiv die werden könnte sich noch
länger da sein was denken sie wie werden
die letzten corona monate von kanzlerin
merkel ausfallen wird sie da so hart
bleiben wie sie gewesen ist in den
vergangenen monaten in den vergangenen
anderthalb jahren
sie wird so hart bleiben weil das
sozusagen das ende ihre eigene
geschichte ist sie wird keine
kurskorrektur vornehmen
das befürchte ich auch ich kann nur
sagen das land aus dem ich komme daher
günther minister press bereits gesagt
ich wirklich schleswig holstein kein
lockdown mehr geben egal was passiert
entscheidend ist nur dass die menschen
dass die veranstaltungs betriebe dass
die gastronomischen betrieb des hotels
sorge davor haben dass nachdem sich
wieder einigermaßen berappelt haben
weswegen der instituts orientierung
dieser regierung wieder zu möglichen
schließungen kommen kann dass viele
mitarbeiter angst haben ich erinnere
daran dass die kieler woche quasi
abgesagt worden ist was die
veranstaltung angeht was für viele der
veranstalter mittlerweile jetzt wirklich
das ökonomische aus bedeutet eine sehr
gewitter wir sind ja sehr schön aber es
sollte wieder volksfest charakter haben
allein diese ankündigung macht einen
wirbel
ich habe nur sagen wenn es uns gelingt
so schnell wie möglich zur normalität
zurückzukehren
dann ist es das was die verfassung uns
auf trägt ganz kurze zwischenfrage weil
er gut wie sie sagen ihr
ministerpräsident schließt das aus aber
die kanzlerin hat dann ja auch wege
gefunden den bundes locker und also
sozusagen auf bundesebene durchzusetzen
also ist es ja dann gar nicht mehr so
ganz entscheidend was die
ministerpräsidenten sagt ja also da muss
die inzidenz über 100 steigen und
vereinigungen wie die bundes notbremse
sie dann wieder in kraft setzen das
parlament was ich ausschließe denn wie
gesagt das gesetz ist ausgelaufen zum
30.6 und müsse neu geschlossen werden
und das wird sie schließlich noch der
kanzlerschaft angela von der zeit der
kanzlerschaft von angela merkel wird es
nicht mehr passieren die schließlich den
lockdown tatsächlich aus und wir
versuchen den menschen damit auch
hoffnung zu machen er laut aber was
glauben sie lockdown dann für nicht
geimpfte zum beispiel oder was passiert
wenn aus ihrer sicht die zahlen zu hoch
gehen in deutschland wesentlich weniger
dramatisch seien die zahlen werden
steigen das ganz klar so wir werden
stark steigende zahlen haben hast
im herbst wenn die dänen haben wir gehen
und da so meine
ob gemütliche prognose ist die dass das
dann dazu führen wird dass also die noch
ungelösten sich zu einem großen teil in
klasse und ich glaube tatsächlich dass
wir da noch die kinder hinten werden was
ich für richtig halte
so dass wir dann noch mal einen schub
haben und was sie die wellen brechen
durch eine zweite also schön mit
massivem in die initiative so es wird zu
sein
diese unterschiedlichen zu sagen wir
regeln für ungeimpfte und für geimpfte
die wird es geben aber kein lotto
das ist kein lockdown also für also
ungewiss
nein aber nicht einen lockt
ausgeschlossen werden kurz paar zahlen
haben aber werde nicht mehr in den
norden gehen das glaub ich noch gas an
wenig ist ein bisschen hoffnung dann für
die nächsten wochen nächsten monate zum
abschluss herr kubicki wir haben
angefangen mit der frage was sozusagen
ja sie am meisten geärgert hat bei ihrem
gegenüber in den vergangenen anderthalb
jahren in der korona debatte welchen
satz wünschen sie sich von karl
lauterbach soll er nie wieder sagen dass
wir hunderttausende von fällen pro tag
haben können das sollte ja nie wieder
sagen ich weiß gar nicht wer weiß nicht
mehr ganz genau was von ihm kommt oder
auch vom rk ii kam oder von von helge
braun im zweifel nature
aber dem war aber ding aber den satz
gesagt er benehme ich mich ausdrücken
dass ich 100 tausend fälle wohl sagt für
nicht da ist nicht denkbar
den habe ich nicht gesagt also damit
müssen sie an anders als auch gut aber
sie haben sie haben sie haben herr
kollege
ich habe einen satz gesagt in der ersten
welle nicht wir werden die schulen die
nächsten zwei jahre nicht wieder
aufmachen und das hat sie
dankenswerterweise nicht bewahren nicht
gesagt
das habe ich das habe ich nur
da ich ganz kurz den satz sagen weil es
was sie gesagt haben was ich gesagt habe
dass wir regulären unterricht wie wir
ihn jetzt kennen anderthalb jahre nicht
haben werden nun genau das ist auch
passiert was genau eingetreten ist ja
nicht gesagt dass die schule so ist aber
also wir haben ja bis heute keinen und
regulären unterricht und die anderthalb
jahre hat ist genau durchdachten
erstellt welcher satz welchen satz von
herrn kubicki wollen sie nie wieder
hören im zusammenhang in der korona
diskussion ja ich also ich würde suchen
egal ersetzen bei ihm aus also alles gut
also jahren an der sache diskutiert von
daher glichkeit ich will keine
vorschriften nachdem dafür nicht der
liberale
er kann sagen was ist richtig es ist
immer eine gute diskussion alles gut
herzlichen vielen dank dass ich mir das
erlauben
herzlichen dank wolfgang kubicki
herzlichen dank karl lauterbach für die
spannende diskussion wie ich fand zu
einem wichtigen thema das uns die
nächsten wochen die nächsten monate
natürlich weiter beschäftigen wird und
das war's mit die richtigen fragen am
heutigen abend alles weitere finden sie
bei bild de und morgen wieder in diesem
studio
[Musik]